uh my pillow Mike Lindell the CEO and
founder of my pillow
is yet again saying he is about to blow
the roof off he's going to blow your
socks off with his latest event the
election crimes Summit this is so hard
to take seriously at this point
the Springfield News Leader announces my
uh Mike pillow MyPillow CEO Mike Lindell
my pillow CEO and prominent election
fraud theorist plans to return to
Springfield Missouri in August to host
an election crime Bureau Summit this
will be August 15 and 16. this is yet
another one of these events at which no
election crimes will be revealed that is
my sense here is Mike pillow with a very
difficult to believe prediction that
this will be the most show most watched
show in world history it's hard to take
it even at all seriously my friends uh
we've got the um
uh election crime Bureau that's going
great we've got this Summit coming up
we're going to keep pushing that August
16th and 17th in Springfield Missouri is
going to be the biggest simul career the
biggest uh Watch program I hope in
history because if you this will be
bigger than the mash finale we're gonna
come up we're going to show everybody
the plan going forward we're going to
say with all the evidence over the last
two years what we can do with it what
can we do with it even though that no
judges are looking at it what are we
doing I love that
every judge is ignoring what we're
saying
but what can we do going beyond that
he's going to let you know that at this
event what can we do so that's going to
be really important yeah and um okay
it's stunning to me that Mike Lindell is
able to say these things with a straight
face is he ever going to drop this I
don't know now you might remember we
recently last week we interviewed uh Bob
zeidman Robert zeidman he is the Cyber
guy
who um is now owed five million dollars
by Mike pillow because Bob zeidman an
admitted Trump supporter voted for Trump
twice
proved Mike pillow's claims wrong Mike
pillow didn't have evidence of a stolen
election in the United States and that
China was involved in it somehow and so
pillow now owns O's Bob zeidman five
million bucks
Zeidman's impression of pillow was that
he was serious about all of these claims
he's a True Believer here is Mike pillow
in this same interview on real America's
voice saying that he is not going to uh
go down uh quietly he's going to try to
not pay Bob the 5 million bucks take a
look at this everyone heard about the
five million dollar Fiasco that
challenged here challenging the uh the
evidence or some of the evidence that I
have and uh we're taking that we're
talking about with the lawyers yesterday
we're taking that to court that's uh
that's a report on that there you go so
he's going to be appealing that have you
seen a guy who seems to love losing more
than Mike pillow he loses everything he
told me he's lost at months ago was 35
million dollars related to all of this
election fraud nonsense he lost 5
million in the finding with Bob zeidman
he loses every time he holds one of
these symposia or as he calls it the
Symposium now it's going to be a summit
it may be easier to pronounce for him he
he just loses everything there's no
ratings no judges are looking at any
losing losing losing and from all
reports and this is said I feel bad for
the guy for this in the sense that I
feel bad for anybody who starts to you
know be alienated from their family
because of their their
I guess Insanity I don't know what else
to call it he seems to really be
struggling personally as a result of all
of this so he's welcome to come back on
the show anytime it's always interesting
to hear from him we had a perfectly
cordial conversation last time but uh
there is some level on which this is
truly very sad